so Ashley stclair posted this video
December
19th and she says my Delta flight from
Phoenix appears to be flying migrants
who cross the border and are being
shipped to New York when I asked a Delta
representative if this was the case his
response was what does it matter they're
humans too lock them
up it is it is it is insane to me that
the gate agents allow people onto the
plane with no name what if one of these
planes we just had a uh what was what
was it we actually have this tweet I
think from from ashle stclair let's P
this story Ashley stclair tweeted hey
United on July 29th the United plane was
nearly total after a hard Landing who
was flying that aircraft was the
co-pilot a former flight attendant who
was fired and then rehired through
United's Diversity Program despite being
on a list to not return to United am I
correct this individual failed multiple
trainings including simulator training
am I also correct that the u United has
covered up this diversity disaster and
many others was the number two 2 at the
Denver hiring center also onboard
through Dei did she or did she not
change fail grades for Dei hires because
it makes the numbers look bad did the
instructor who failed this co-pilot ask
corporate why they passed him Elon Musk
responds if this is true this puts a lot
of lives at
risk it is true my friends if there are
employees of Airlines who are allowing
people onto planes without giving their
names you thought 911 was bad we knew
the names of those guys now they're
letting hundreds if not thousands every
day and they have no idea who they are
and so when I hear something about a
plane nearly being total to hard Landing
I get freaked out am I going to board a
plane where there are people on it that
did not pass security and we don't know
who they are and then what happens if
they hijack the plane there's no
security screen there's no vetting of
these
individuals I had to go I have TSA Prix
so I have to go for a meeting where I
give all my information bring my my ID
cards and then I get to keep my shoes on
when I go through security when I travel
my friends they got to take their shoes
off these people don't even have to give
their
names that's insane but I think it goes
to show
you I I you know Marjorie Taylor green
has talked about National divorce you do
not have a country if laws are being
broken and Mass to the tune of 10,000
plus every day and it's not just 10,000
laws each of these individuals who are
leg cross the border are breaking a
multitude of laws each of the employees
of these Airlines these Bus Charters and
these uh uh private Charters every one
of those employees are breaking the law
too at this point laws are basically not
being enforced at all in this country
only selectively against the political
opponents of unip party establishment
figures I don't know how you have an
argument that the United States
exists well back to the immigration like
for people who don't want to enforce
immigration laws you got to ask the
question should we have any immigration
laws at all if we have any laws no
matter what they are any laws at all at
some point if it's broken will you
deport anybody and you know for those
who say it's heartless like the woman
said they people too and stuff like that
the the the gate attendant who said to
the lady other people too does she
believe in enforcing any laws related
immigration or can anyone come here 500
billion Chinese can arrive tomorrow well
they're people too let them all in so
it's either you have a law and you
enforce it or you don't and enforcing
any law is always uncomfortable in just
to take the immigration away from a
second say a man commits a robbery gets
caught gets sentenced to 5 years of jail
that main man may have a 5-year-old
child at home who doesn't want his daddy
to go to jail but Daddy broke the law so
therefore you have to enforce it and yes
innocent people that the 5-year-old
child loses his father for 5 years
because the father robbed the store
that's enforc so it's not an easy or UNC
uh comfortable thing to do always to
enforce the law but either we have the
rule of law or we don't whether you like
it or not whether it's comfortable or
not whether you think it's Humane or not
not it's it's it's do you believe in
actually enforcing laws any laws well
they don't they the left doesn't there's
a video going viral right now of a man
being arrested because he jumped Turnell
in uh the New York Metro and they're all
saying oh my God why are the police
doing this to this man and I'm like
because he broke the law and they're
like but why are they being so violent
because he's resisting arrest and
fighting with them they should let him
go that's ridic they should enforce the
law yeah there's no law but they don't
want the law enforced no and if they get
their way these leftists
then you may as well not own land you
may as well not have a job they're going
to come into your house they're going to
take whatever they want no one's going
to enforce the law that's the world they
live in that I mean that's the desire
the idea you know there are people on
the left that think that even owning
property is somehow oppressive so the
the idea that you own anything is is
offensive to them but when you're
talking about like the the way that they
they behave when it comes to enforcing
the law this is something that I harp on
again there's this guy in the 60s called
uh Herbert maruse that wrote up a paper
called the uh was it the uh um Li uh
oppressive tolerance and essentially the
argument he made in the paper was that
if you are on the left you should
forgive whatever people on the left are
doing up to an including violence and if
you are if you on the left and you're
dealing with someone on the right then
they should be silenced they should be
uh you know they should be censored as
much as possible up to an including
thought if possible so you can't have a
a society where half the society
believes that the other half of the
society shouldn't have the ability to
express themselves to talk any of their
ideas must be shouted down and that's
this impulse we see constantly on the
left and it's something that that is a a
big problem because we've got got a
society that doesn't even listen to you
know we we we constantly are bickering
and we don't hear each other out and
there's been studies that people in the
center and on the right know and
understand the arguments from the people
on the left the people on the left
straight up are so obsessed with the
ideology they just think if you don't
think like us you must be evil that's
why it's always bigotry always some kind
of some kind of moral failing so any
other somebody Frederick basat you know
book legal legal plunder where if you go
and take somebody's money from and Rob
it from their house you're going to jail
but if you pass set of laws to create a
tax system and you take 70% of what they
earn it's legal all of a sudden right so
that's what's called Legal plunder and
it seems like a whole another thing is
to just not enforce laws that people may
not like selectively speaking based on
situations like someone uh not paying to
go into the Metro System jumping over
the metro line or you know other and
they have this debate in in cities
whether you enforce loitering um you
know smaller like throwing rocks through
Windows some cities Broken Window yeah
they just choose not to enforce those
whatsoever which obviously leads to
Greater and worse crimes yeah the idea
that you can allow some crimes to go un
unpunished or whatever just be like oh
well this is a crime but we're going to
ignore it yeah you can't do that because
that degrades the law overall like you
there should probably be significantly
fewer laws in most major cities right
like the the essentially the government
can do whatever they want whenever they
want they've got enough laws where they
can just say okay well you you broke
this law so we started the interaction
etc etc that being said um it doesn't
mean that the government should have
interactions with you all the time you
know they the there should be there
should be a limit to the am an amount
that the government is going to be
involved with you and it certainly
shouldn't be deciding oh we're not going
to enforce this law for you but this guy
over here we're going to look at the guy
that Daniel penny guy that in uh the guy
that that ended up accidentally killing
a guy um you know he wasn't the only guy
that was trying to stop him you know and
there were there have been other people
that have done significantly worse
crimes you know that that aren't being
held on $200,000 Bond or whatever you
know and and I think that that's that's
the the the inconsistency and the
insecurity of the population is the goal
because then you're too afraid to break
the rules or even get close to breaking
the rules it's like by any means
necessary becomes a thing it's like it's
always been by means necessary and then
just everything everything like Falls
kind of makes sense once you look at
that and realize that's like the
underlying message behind it all yeah
yeah got to have equal enforcement of
the law it's just a yeah it's like how
how little are we asking here you know
and you talk about they always call
conservatives names like racists and
stuff they're the ones selectively
enforcing the law we're just saying
enforce the law the same regardless of
any ethnicity race everything just be
equal to everyone that's that's white
supremacy that's what they call that why
VI doesn't said he wouldn't condemn it
because he knows what they're saying is
color blindness is white supremacy
correct what the woke left want is
racial segregation so that's what
they've actually been implementing
across the country and then they use
these code words to trick you and to
make you bend the knee yeah I think go I
find that at least as far as people
running for office there's a great fear
of being called a name like a racist or
a hater of any particular person or
group of people and the fear of being
called a name uh is is no excuse not to
do the right thing like secure the
Border you know you know enforce
immigration laws doesn't mean you don't
love everyone sure you can love everyone
I just think we should actually enforce
the laws of our country or we have no
laws in this country and those who want
lawlessness and selective enforcement
are the ones who are actually picking
and choosing government picking and
choosing winners and losers based on
ethnicity and things like that just like
they want to pick the winners and losers
based on the energy you know coal let's
go after coal and it's got to be all
solar pain you know government's picking
win winners and losers and abusing their
powers all over the place so Ashley
stclair is who tweeted I'm in possession
of legitimate major airline boarding
passes for migrants that quite literally
have the name printed as quote no name
given incredibly difficult to post these
without putting the Insiders at risk
working on it this will continue to
unfold over the coming weeks but I can
confirm these are legitimate boarding
passes I at a loss for words for what I
am verifying thank you to everybody
reaching out so if you if you guys
choose to believe it you don't think
Ashley St Clair is on the level I think
she is on the level I know her
personally and I think she is very
honest and I don't think she would lie
about this that being said I look
forward to the release of these images
you should be able to in some way
release them but it is true because
whoever printed them out the companies
will know who printed them out it is
also true that I will say to Ashley and
to those insiders you must be brave and
you need to stop working for a company
that is breaking the law and blow the
whistle before you are the one who ends
up in prison you know we need more
everyday American heroes like that in
this country we got a woman in Hardy
County West Virginia who the EPA
declared a trickle of water was a river
and was requiring her a farm to go over
all sorts of EPA regulations this is
when I first elected and she sued with
the support of the American Farm Bureau
sued all the way to Supreme Court and
won won the case they offered her
settlements along the way but she said
no I'm not going to settle because this
isn't just for me and my farm it's for
all farmers and everyday American Heroes
uh can do this and need to stand up uh
and I would applaud anybody that would
under a variety of circumstances you
know whistleblowers who undercover
corruption and show what's actually
happening because there's a lot of
misinformation a lot of hiding what's
happening the left wants to do things
and not let you know do it in secret
they're saying in politics sunlight is
the best disinfectant and I love that
saying and you know we have of course
control in the house now and I do
applaud my good friends Jim Jordan and
James comr who run those committees for
bringing out whistleblowers who are
talking about corruption and covered up
evidence from the left and the unfair
application of the law this is important
for our country uh that that they
whistle blow that and I think you know
showing that makes a difference and you
can lead to the investigations we do
have subpoena power now on the house and
you know what they've arrested
Republicans for now you know Hunter
Biden won't won't come testify so you
you have double equal unequal
application of the law there as far as
committee hearings so uh we really have
to expose this stuff and I think that's
one of the things this show is about and
I appreciate that thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a member
over at timcast.net